cela van der leyen la présidente de la
commission européenne a annoncé une aide
500 millions d'euros dead humanitaire le
destin de l'union européenne est en jeu
en ukraine on en parle avec vous aviez
schmith heures bonjour les mots utilisés
par la présidente de la commission open
mais aussi par le chancelier allemand
olaf scholz sont à très fort ça y est
l'europe agit et vas y tire fort alors
l'europe agit l'europe a commencé à agir
quasiment 20 heures après l'intervention
le début de l'intervention russe en
prenant les premières sanctions mais et
tout le monde est conscient que ce n'est
pas suffisant
cette fois ci il en va des valeurs
européennes c'est ce qu'on entend à la
fois dans les discours des différents
responsables des institutions
européennes que ce soit la présente du
parlement roberta mais cela qu'on a
entendu précédemment le
le président e
du conseil également on a entendu pour
cela von der leyen qui vous le rappeliez
a eu un discours assez fort la façon
dont nous répondons aujourd'hui à ce que
fait la russie déterminera l'avenir du
système international le destin de
l'ukraine est en jeu mais notre propre
destin est également dans la balance
nous devons montrer la puissance qui
résident dans nos démocraties en gros
c'est ce qu'on pourra retenir de 2 de
son intervention ça fait écho à ce que
disais à l'instant le président dennis
client qu'est intervenu environ
conférence il ya les valeurs il ya les
hommes on parle de 500 millions d'euros
mais on parle surtout de plus de 600
milles ukrainiens qui sont actuellement
sur les routes qui fuient les combats et
puis on parle aussi d'ukrainiens qui eux
et bien sont sur le front est bien sont
en train de résister à l'incursion à
l'invasion russe naturellement la façon
dont l'union européenne répondra est
forcément une façon qui est
attendu attendu à la fois par les russes
est attendu par les ukrainiens il ya eu
l'extinction il ya eu l'aide en matériel
militaire mais l'union européenne sait
pertinemment que ça ne suffira pas et
puis on sait que cette histoire entre
l'ukraine et l'union européenne est une
très longue histoire puisque la première
demande d'adhésion remonte à 1995 mais
l'idée de cette adhésion ukrainiennes à
l'union européenne elle a aussi épousé
les les soubresauts de l'histoire et de
l'union européenne d'ailleurs et de
l'ukraine qui a eu à abandonner sa tête
aussi une présidence pro russe qui avait
mis de côté toute alliance possible avec
l'union européenne en quoi cette réunion
parlement européen elle était importante
pour volodymyr zelensky que contient la
résolution que vont voter les
eurodéputés qui n'est pas contraignant
tant le rapport la proposition n'est pas
contraignante elle a une valeur
symbolique néanmoins déjà on a vu
d'ailleurs il l'a rappelé le président
céline ce qui est
je suis ravi de voir que eux
on a pu unir les institutions
européennes derrière l'ukraine le
problème c'est de l'avoir fait à ce prix
là c'est à dire au prix des combats et
au prix de du poids et bien des victimes
et des gens qui fit l'ukraine à l'heure
actuellement à l'heure actuelle très
clairement ce qu'il ya dans cette dans
cette résolution qui va être adopté
très clairement par le parlement puisque
tous les groupes parlementaires à
l'exception de l'extrême droite se sont
dits favorables à cette résolution mais
aussi une résolution qui dit qu il faut
non pas intégré sans délai l'union
européenne comme le demandait hier le
président céline ski cette procédure
n'existe pas mais une procédure
d'adhésion qui est d'ailleurs inscrite
désormais dans la constitution
ukrainienne depuis trois ans je crois
que tout simplement cette adhésion soit
prise en compte mais les termes de la
résolution qu'on a pu
regardez en fin de fin de matinée
c'était une résolution sur lesquels les
députés devaient voter mais qui allait
respecter d'après eux un traitement de
base à savoir la procédure habituelle et
notamment celles de l'article 49 selon
lequel les mérites notamment du du pays
candidats doivent être évaluées ça veut
dire passer par la commission ça veut
dire un accord des 27 on sait que au
niveau des 27 certains pays issu de l'ex
bloc de l'est sont particulièrement
favorables à l'intégration de l'ukraine
dans l'union européenne c'est vrai pour
la tchéquie qui en a fait l'appel
dernièrement disant que c'est vrai que
c'est extraordinaire que la procédure
n'existe pas avec la situation en
ukraine est elle même extraordinaire
c'est vrai de la slovénie c'est vrai de
certains pays balle c'est vrai de la
pologne qui accueille actuellement
énormément de réfugiés et qui néanmoins
considère qu' il faut intégrer la
pologne et puis il ya d'autres pays qui
sont sans doute un peu moins favorable
c'est ce que disait charles michel près
précédemment c'est que et bien au sein
de l'union européenne il ya 27 pays il
ya des pays qui vont dire qu'au niveau
démocratique et adroit parce qu'ils sont
parmi les critères qui vont être
étudiées lors d'une candidature et bien
l'ukraine peut ne pas y répondre
d'autres vont étudier les les aspects
économiques on sait que ça sera le cas
de ses rangs doutes de certains pays
occidentaux
on ne peut avoir des surprises avec
notamment très longtemps la hongrie qui
refusait d'intégrer l'ukraine a
à l'union européenne considérant de son
côté par exemple et bien que vladimir
poutine pourrait utiliser cette adhésion
à des fins militaires on est en plein
dedans merci beaucoup vous avez en tout
cas pour la présidente de la commission
européenne au sol avant darién les
ukrainiens font partie de l'europe à la
réitérer un des propos très fort à
l'égard des ukrainiens l'écoutent
we want to day la façon dont nous
répondons aujourd'hui est ce que fait la
russie déterminera l'avenir du système
international
le destin de l'ukraine est en jeu mais
notre propre dessin est également dans
la balance
nous devons montrer la puissance qui
résident dans nos démocraties